[Music]
you know my biggest fear is not being
successful what's your biggest fear I
honestly think my biggest fear is also
not being successful you don't want to
you know just leave the earth with
nothing that proved to everybody that
you were actually here and made impact
so yeah pretty sure mine is the same
thing the biggest life lesson I've
learned is everything happens for a
reason
what the event in your life have you
struggled accepting that ended up
turning out for the better so once me
and my family move to another country
and so I was kind of blaming that
experience for like some bad things that
was happening but later I figured out
that it means like my life was so much
better because that thing happens so
yeah
that's if you could find out when you
will die would you like to know and why
I would love to know because there's so
many things in life I'd want to do
before I die
and when I die I want to make sure I
check off everything off my bucket list
what to find success to you I think that
success is feeling fulfilled in your
life and being able to accomplish goals
that you set for yourself what is the
source of your happiness in life so my
source populace would probably going to
the gym helps a really stress and I feel
happy doing it I feel good
how do you ask a go for her number
just gotta be straightforward with it
you gotta go up and be confident ask for
a number
oh no no no nothing okay what do you
look for in a partner um I think for the
most part I just look for a best friend
somebody that's gonna understand you and
be with you through it off that's a very
deep question
[Music]
I hope your day is good and things get
better for you if you had the power to
change the world what would you do to
have it be a better place
honestly if I had the power to change
the world I would build shelters and
homes for the for the kids who would
need it and deserve it too and like
schools for the kids that would love to
have the privilege that we do to go to
school and get their education you had
the power to change one negative in the
world what would you change if I were to
change one negative in the world it
would be that people shouldn't have open
access to guns if you could have a meal
with anyone dead or alive who would you
choose I would have a meal with my
grandma because I feel like I didn't get
to really tell her how much I appreciate
her when she was alive every day is a
new day a fresh start don't forget to
remind yourself how beautiful you are
the barnacle has the longest penis to
body size ratio of any animal don't
judge yourself by petty attributes but
by who you are
it was pretty a pretty neat fact that
they left for me learn something new
every day I guess
Jeremy Harris thinks he's better than me
because he gets veggies in his
sandwiches never let someone get you
down get whatever you want on your own
sandwich all right it's like a metaphor
to life you know like you can put
whatever you want on your sandwich but
it's up to you you do you that's they
enjoy your sandwich that we don't let
anybody tell you what slurring of
dentwich so that's all I have to say
just do whatever you want love is like a
table for two you you got to love
yourself before you invite other people
to your table
beautiful really yeah I like it
[Music]
three here's you're not doing on the
bottom please do me a favor and put away
your phone for a day I have to put maybe
for half a No
[Music]
if you meet an international student you
should invite him /her to a party they
are very funny I had a best friend who
was from Japan and she would take me to
all kinds of like little places that she
found in the city and I was able to show
her places that I found and she was able
to teach me some Japanese and I was
the hope teacher some English so you can
make friends to international students
and it's whole other doors different
ways that people see the world so this
person yeah you should invite an
international student to a party or just
to hang out with you to eat lunch
[Music]
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video and share it a couple episodes
with friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]